tonight a sign the holiday spirit is
still here ted florendo joining us from
glittering lights at the las vegas motor
speedway great family activity your kind
of social distance just that
as it is ted good spot
yeah this is a great spot for everybody
to go to with that social distancing for
sure because you can jump in the car
and uh you'll be free you don't have to
worry about anybody being with you other
than your family
and you can drive through the the
glittering lights here of course
it begins today it's been going on for
20 years can you believe it this is the
20th year for that
and of course they don't have the lights
on just yet because it's going to begin
shortly here with bmx star ricardo
laguna my buddy's going to jump over
hit that button there with his bike and
it's going to kick off the lights and
there's actually fireworks down
here too all right let's check out the
forecast because of course it's a nice
cool night tonight a little chilly for
sure but you'll be in your cars right
temperatures at this hour again are in
the mid 60s but look at the high for the
day today
high 60s today put us right near average
43 overnight for the low
currently outside like we talked about
nice and cool outside
wind speeds are staying at least light
breeze outside mainly light but there's
some breezes out there
in some of those neighborhoods to the
south here's your evening planner clear
skies nice and cool this evening
mid to high 50s 55 for eight news now at
11. again light breezes for tonight
light winds tomorrow 53 degrees at 8 00
a.m back live now one good thing about
the gift of
or the glaring lights is that you can
fit everybody
on the car you pay one price which is 25
during the weekdays and 35 on the
weekends but you can fit as many people
as you want in one car
and come down here and check out the
lights there's now an extra million
lights down here to check out
we'll talk about that we'll show you
those glittering lights
and we'll also have more on your main
forecast all coming up in just a couple
minutes
reporting live down here at the las
vegas motor speedway i'm ted florento 8
news now we'll see you down here